what about the agents involved is anyone
telling their stories well imagine
if a massive humanity charged at you
wanting to enter your home
maybe come live with you for a while
throwing rocks and waving
another country's flag well while the
agents themselves aren't able to speak
out at the moment
they are allowed to talk with their
representatives one joins us now
to share what he's learned hector garza
is the national border patrol council
president
and is with us tonight from san antonio
hector
what are the people on your team telling
you on the ground you just saw
a report about what happened another a
very
emotional uh woman who said they just
started throwing tear gas canisters at
us
that's not actually what happened but
that's what she said
uh what did they encounter well our
agents were actually uh under attack
they were assaulted these migrants were
throwing rocks
they were throwing glass bottles and
they were also throwing other debris
that was in the area
and as a matter of fact some of our ages
were hit uh on their head
on their helmets uh with these rocks and
there were minor injuries
there was also damage to government
vehicles uh and their windows were
broken so
this is an assault this is an invasion
on our agents on the country
and our agents had to respond with a
very low level
uh force which is the the tear gas
that was deployed now we have heard from
everyone from mexican government
officials to guatemalan officials who've
said from the beginning that the use of
women and children at the front of these
lines whether they're crossing
uh the bridge into mexico from
guadalajara
or breaking the border into guatemala
from honduras
that this was done very deliberately
with careful planning
uh and that unfortunately the children
end up as casualties the ones who aren't
trafficked
are end up as casualties in all this or
injured or traumatized
but they want to blame hector president
trump
because i guess the border should just
be open and people should be able to
come in
100 at a time and fill out a form and
say
i want asylum well these if these
people think that they're going to do
the same thing that they did on the on
the guatemala
mexico border they're wrong our agents
are properly trained
they're going to be using reasonable
force and something that they're
reporting to us
is that these migrants were using these
children as human shields
as they were launching rocks at our
agents so they had no
regard for human life uh they did not
care about the other migrants
they did not care about the kids and our
ages did a great job by using these
this tear gas to be able to disperse the
crowd
now our agents could have been justified
to use a higher level of force
but they did not they use they used a
very low level of force
and they were successful they did a
great job out there but hector what if
the numbers
increase what if they swell and well
we're gonna have to keep using the same
the same strategy
uh uh the good thing is that we have the
military and that's what president trump
did for us
uh we're gonna have we're gonna have to
deploy more resources to the uh to the
area
but it is going to get out of control
and that's why congress needs to act and
we have to make sure that we do build
that wall
so that we can avoid these type of
confrontations because people will end
up getting hurt
now again outrageous are properly
trained and they're going to do the best
job
that they can out there but again these
these caravans they need to stop and we
need to do our job
and also mexico has to do uh their job
as well in helping us on the southern
border
they should never have been trucked up
to the border many of them were trucked
up uh they should never been allowed to
cross into mexico
there's a series of things that had to
happen for this situation
to result in the crisis that it is today
hector
thank you very much and please thank the
border patrol for us they're doing
incredible work under very difficult
circumstances
and being maligned by everyone from
hollywood actors and actresses
who themselves how many how many
immigrants would they sponsor in their
homes if they had to
uh and you know politicians and business
types so we really thank you so much